Your authentic leftism is populist.
Okay.
It is based in working class style,
working class language,
working class,
direct emotion and an openness and
brushing some speech.
Okay.
Not this fancy,
contorted jargon of the pseudo leftist
of academe who are frauds.
These people,
these people who managed to manage to
rise to the top and ended at Berkeley
and Harvard and Princeton.
Okay.
You have any of these people are
radical.
They are career people.
Their corporate types.
Okay.
Then who like who succeeded in and they
love the institutional context.
They know how to manipulate the
bureaucracy which has totally invaded in
usurped.
Okay.
The or they have an academe everywhere.
These people are company poor players.
They could have done well in any,
any field,
and then they,
they love to sit in endless committees.
They love bureaucratic regulation and so
on.
There's not one,
not one leftist.
Okay.
And American academe raised his or her
voice against obscene growth.
Growth of tuition costs which have
bankrupted a whole generation of young
people.
Not,
not one voice.
Okay.
To challenge that.
That invasion by the bureaucrats.
Okay.
Actual fascist bureaucrats.
Well,
if whoever added the cancerous,
okay,
there's so many of them can.
If they told the faculty have completely
lost any power in American academia.
Okay.
It's us.
It's a scandal.
What has happened and they deserve the
president's servitude that they're in
right now.
Okay.
Because they never protested.
When I.
my first job at Bennington College,
1976.
I was there when there was an uprising
by the faculty against encroachment,
by the board of trustees and the
president.
Okay.
And it was a huge thing.
It was,
it was.
It was reported on the New York Times
and so on.
And we.
And we pushed that president out and,
and there's not been a single uprising
of mankind against,
against encroachment,
by the trustees and by the
administrations and all these decades.
Okay.
Passive slaves.
Slaves.
They deserve their slavery.
Yup.
I couldn't agree more.
I thought the same thing about
university professors for a long time is
that they get exactly what they deserve
because they never stand up and say no.
And the fact that in the United States,
it's not quite as bad in Canada,
I wouldn't say,
but the fact that the students have been
essentially handed a bill of indentured
servitude here for the student loans is
absolutely beyond comprehension.
You know,
it seems to me that the bureaucracy has
basically conspired to determine how to
pick the pockets of the students' future
earnings.
Right?
And they do that by offering them an
extended adolescence with no quality
control,
something like that.
So it's a real bargain with the devil.